bonsoir mes chèvres info merci d'être
avec nous alors une décision symbolique
mais une défaite diplomatique de la
syrie de ses alliés ou une décision
politique comme le dit la russie je
crois que c'est une décision politique
évidemment ce n'est pas seulement une
décision politique
finalement on est devant une fuite en
avant des pays occidentaux
une fuite en avant dans le thé ni dans
le mensonge dans l'intoxication dans la
fabrication des faits qui concernent pas
seulement d'ailleurs l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques et
qui concerne que toute la mouvance
disons onusienne le globalement plus
qu'un soin au conseil de sécurité ou
ailleurs je crois que c'est désolant car
ce en dépit du domaine de la diplomatie
c'est du domaine de je ne sais pas quoi
de la donne
la fantaisie salue les domaines de
l'analyse politique c'est du domaine de
la psychanalyse plutôt comme le disait
finalement là quelques années déjà un
agent des services de renseignement qui
est restée dans l'anonymat plus ou moins
mais qu'il d'avouer qu'ils aient on lui
demandait si les états occidentaux ne
pourrait pas faire un tel ou tel geste
pour essayer d'améliorer ou bien de
rétablir des contacts avec la syrie ou
avec que ce soit un mot moins anormales
dix ans il disait non nous ne pouvons
pas décidément parce que nous sommes
allés trop loin dans la voie du mensonge
de l'intoxication de l'ain fox de
l'intox et de la manipulation pour
revenir en arrière et je crois que ça
c'est une illustration
à défaut de pouvoir faire autre chose eh
bien on sent donc on persiste dans
l'avant s'ajoutent c'est une voie sans
issue
parce que bien évidemment le disons
privait la syrie de ses droits à loyat c
est de son droit de vote et de ses
participations je crois que c'est un peu
illusoire
il ya belle lurette que la syrie ne
comptent plus là dessus de contenus sur
leurs yeux assez pour assurer dirait la
légalité internationale dont il ya ces
s'est distingué jusqu'à présent
justement par le traficotage ddd des
procédures par là
je dirais la tromperie dans les moyens
dans l'est dans les dents dans les
enquêtes c'est toutes les irrégularités
qui avaient fait l'objet d'ailleurs de
de l'halal la pétition qu'elle avait été
lancée la lettre de préoccupation qui
avait été lancée par l'ancien premier
directeur général de l'opep destin
tension contre les diables la diffusion
de temps chimique
l'ambassadeur chose des mousses thani et
qui appelait ainsi liés par de grandes
personnalités notamment américaines et
qui a appelé finalement le lot il ya
c'est à le revoir c'est un peu celle de
s'inquiéter nizon de la façon dont ces
procédures sont systématiquement trafic
est détournée par un certain nombre
groupes de pays
disons qu'ils sont un volet b
occidentaux pour parler clair je crois
que c'est ça le problème
en tout cas jacques guillet les excès on
le sait utiliser du sahara un accord
lors des attaques heures en mars 2010
est sur le village de l'été menez est ce
que ce n'est pas sur tout le monde
réponse aux interrogations de l'eau y
est c qui est sanctionné non je crois
que c'est le traficotage des enquêtes et
des procédures internes de l'oeil à ces
suppressions des trois pays occidentaux
les étés pour ne pas les nommer les
états unis la grande bretagne et la
france c'est la banque qui a fait
basculer les choses justement au je
crois pas qu'ils ont su tourner ce
n'était pas beaucoup plus glorieux
néanmoins je pense que la solidarité
occidentale s'est montré plus vigoureuse
depuis que baye donne est revenu parce
que les dix ont un petit peu moins
polémique intimement imprévisible que
donald trump fond sur le fond ça n'est
pas plus glorieux
joe by donne quand même un passif
c'est pas un passé politique seulement
un passif politique notamment en ce qui
concerne des pays du grand moyen-orient
tous les prêts les pays arabes les pays
arabo musulmans c'est à dire de les
opérations démocrates soit disant
démocratisation en fait cette opération
de destruction de déstabilisation pour
la plus grande gloire d'israël je crois
que c'est ça qui est inquiétant qui dans
qui est en jeu actuellement la rue
bayard revient en arrière quand on a
trop menti quand on est comment voulez
vous que des états qui se disent la
fleur de l'humanité puisse revenir en
art
hier et dire on s'est trompé et b
qu'user nous c'est pas possible
et donc c'est désolant pour le droit
international ya plus de droite rance
yoda et c'est ça le problème
en plus j'ai dit aux gars qui a une
paire qu il ya une conjoncture actuelle
qui est marquée notamment par le
soi-disant dixième anniversaire de la
dea début des événements syrie de la
guerre de syrie donc on fait tout pour
persévérer dans la même foi puisque on
ne peut plus revenir en arrière parce
qu'on était trop loin dans le mensonge
est donc réduit à la perspective des
élections présidentielles en syrie qui
sont décrétés davance illégale
illégitime et ses aplombs le une fois
pour toutes finalement ils
n'appartiennent ni à l'amérique ni à la
france
ces élections pardonnez moi on sait rien
on parle aussi de reconstruction de la
syrie damas ce qu'annonce la tenue d'un
scrutin présidentiel le 26 mai ça veut
dire que louis assez
voilà marque un petit peu ça parte cet
instant-là précis stratégique pour le
pays
je crois que c'est pas le haut il ya ce
qui est en jeu c'est la faction de la
façon de fonctionner de loyat c'est josé
boustany le cac est le premier directeur
général de l'aeia c'est avaient une
opinion qui était à fait divers ce jeu
neutre et que la lettre qui a été
adressée à l'actuel directeur de loyat
c'est finalement lui demander de revoir
les procédures et s'inquiétait des
pressions et du détournement des
procédures
disons par les trois pays occidentaux la
grande bretagne la france et les états
unis bien évidemment alors je crois il
faut pas oublier que des dp qui n'hésite
pas la menace conflit personnel je
rappellerai que john bolton que je
trouve ce grognon de l'équipe précédente
finalement dix ans avait menacé josé
boustany à l'époque de la guerre d'irak
un peu dans son dans son avis la vienne
à 100 sa famille en or nous savons sur
vos enfants ce qui est indigne du
représentant d'une grande puissance
je crois que loïc assez de voter la
suspension ça ne suspendra pas grand
chose pas beaucoup de droit du goût de
vote de la syrie parce que la syrie
appelle lurette qu'elle n'attend plus
rien du tout de loria c'est sinon les
condamnations puisque sa pompe tonne
cette façon là elle n'attend plus rien
de l'occident dit la communauté
internationale parce que c'est de cette
façon que ça fonctionne et notre est que
tout ce qui est pris les décisions de
l'homme de la communauté internationale
actuellement telle qu'elle est à
l'occidentale c'est-à-dire dirigé par
les trois membres permanents occidentaux
du conseil de sécurité est bien celle ça
aboutit à détruire au fond rayer la
syrie de la carte
c'est un politicien et un ethnocide
comme on dirait peut-être pas un
génocide enfin quoi coach des mesures
génocidaire qui sont prises parce qu'un
soldat cyril et tragique du peuple
syrien et de l'état série et on cherche
à éradiquer et enrayer la série de la
carte je pense que la décision de l'eau
il ya ces quêtes une décision sur
sanction
sous une forte pression des trois beaux
grands pays occidentaux qui se croient à
la fleur de la communauté internationale
eh bien je crois que ça ne fait que
confirmer cet état
c'est désolant du point de vue du droit
international je pense qu'il n'y a plus
de diplomatie possible il n'y a plus de
raisonnement possible on dirait ils ont
une société folle soirée
clients palais il s'agissit remettre de
l'ordre un petit peu là dedans merci
michel raimbault d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france